and have you not done any therapy i went  twice when they split my mom made me go  to a marriage counselor and the guy was  like he had a little plastic hoop  and uh basketball yeah and i would  always come in and shoot because i'm a  big basketball guy and i would shoot and  and  for probably the whole hour and then  like sit down for the last five minutes  and you'd be like  so uh  are you feeling any better when i go  no no  see you next week and you just wouldn't  push me and then one day i remember went  in and i shot and uh  bounced off the rim you just [ __ ] one  arm grab the offensive rebound and goes  we're gonna talk today  no more shooting hoops until we talk and  i was like oh tim allen style he was  serious yeah i sat down and i still  barely opened up and i was just like who  the [ __ ] are you man